A peek behind the curtain on Game of Thrones
will reveal a number of things that may surprise
even the show’s most die-hard fans, from
the special effects in play to the true-life
relationships of the cast and crew.
These are some of the most intriguing set
images from the show’s production.
While it should come as no surprise that the
real-life relationships between professional
actors rarely mirror the characters they portray,
it can still throw you for a loop to discover
bitter onscreen rivals are in fact super-great
buds.
Such was the case with Pedro Pascal, who played
the fiery, doomed Oberyn Martell, and Hafþór
Júlíus Björnsson, who played his sworn
enemy, Ser Gregor Clegane.
Their shocking duel in season 4 remains one
of the most memorable moments of the series.
That's why this picture of the two actors
soaking up rays together seems so odd.
But while the difference between their onscreen
and offscreen relationship may inspire a double
take or two, that contrast in their real-life
physiques is exactly how they were depicted
on the show, with Björnsson towering over
his svelte pal.
Anyone who has ever spent time on a set knows
the important roles that stand-ins and stunt
doubles play.
These individuals provide coverage for the
actors between, and sometimes even during,
filming.
Actress Emilia Clarke's stand-in and stunt
double, Rosie Mac, has received a good share
of media attention over the course of the
show's run, thanks in part to the backstage
photos she often posts on her social media
accounts.
And you’ve got to admit: all these stand-ins
look so similar to the show's famous leads
that it's actually kinda difficult to tell
them apart at first glance.
As important as the actors are in bringing
the world of Game of Thrones to life, so too
are the crew members.
Naturally, a story this epic in scope and
length requires hundreds of professionals
working tirelessly at their craft.
Among the most important of these crew members
is Deborah Riley, who serves as the series'
lead production designer.
One of the reasons the show has caught on
with so many people is because it feels so
real.
Of course, it feels so real because much of
it is: many of the grand locales are shot
on location, rather than on a stage or studio
backlot.
But this illusion is further cemented by the
intricate, but subtle, set decoration and
design, which captures the viewer's attention
without being so dazzling as to distract from
the drama of the story or the performances
of the actors.
"You understand the textures, you understand
the colors, you understand the palette, you
understand so many things about the culture
that you're trying to recreate."
Of course, not every locale that appears on
Game of Thrones is the real deal.
Location filming isn't always an option, so
in order to achieve a believable replication,
the effects crew will alternate between real
and digital locations.
This type of visual trickery is nothing new
in and of itself, and Hollywood movies have
long used painted backdrops as stand-ins for
practical scenery.
But this seamless blending of outdoor filming
with mobile greenscreens is just one of the
modern era’s most impressive achievements
in the field of CGI.
Given how unforgettable many of these large-scale
scenes have proven, it's fair to say that
the show's special effects team has perfected
this kind of digital enhancement.
Sadly, not everything on Game of Thrones can
be done with practical effects.
In fact, one of the questions fans of the
books asked when the series was first announced
was just how such an epic story could be realistically
adapted to the screen.
This was of particular concern since television
wasn’t exactly known for grand spectacle
at the time.
And foremost among their concerns was the
show's ability to bring Daenerys Targaryen’s
dragons to life.
"I'm here to help.
Don't eat the help."
Luckily, it turned out the showrunners knew
exactly what they were doing.
As a result, they've given us arguably the
definitive screen dragons of the modern era.
But for these fantastical creatures, practical
effects just weren't practical.
And yes, this might all look a bit silly,
but it really goes to show just what CGI can
really do.
It’s always pretty remarkable to see the
show's actors on location, battling against
the elements.
Such is the case with this image posted to
Instagram by Carice van Houten, who plays
the sinister witch Melisandre.
On the show, she's utterly unflappable.
She can stoically weather her surroundings
no matter how harsh the conditions, thanks
to the power she's achieved through her practice
of the dark arts.
In real life, however, van Houten is just
as susceptible to the cold as the rest of
us mere mortals.
It just goes to show, being a successful actor
isn't always as glamorous as it's made out
to be.
One thing that should come as no surprise
to fans of the show by now is the close bond
shared between various cast members.
Considering how many characters have been
killed off during the story so far, you’ve
got to imagine those cast members have probably
gotten used to saying goodbye to one another...
which is why it's cool to see they still hang
out with veterans from earlier seasons, such
as Jason Momoa, who played the late, great
Khal Drogo.
According to Momoa's Instagram account, he
met up with his Game of Thrones buds in Belfast
during filming for the final season.
Of course, these pictures sparked plenty of
speculation that the once-and-future Aquaman
would be returning to the series in some capacity
during its final season.
Whether that turns out to be the case or not,
it's still always nice to see old friends
keeping in touch.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.